[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back top the record do
we talk about what we want we got to
hear back hey we got all the big mood
girls except for death oh yeah yeah and
we got Corey Feldman just thinking this
[ __ ] funny
oh yeah thank you man it's like it just
doesn't turn on like whole don't turn it
off I tried - that was funny that was
still funny thank you guys thank you for
having me back
cuz I love you you know I mean don't
tell anyone else this and this is a
secret you guys - but um my top favorite
three guess besides everyone else in
this room wait who's our top three why
is it me now between Gina Nicki and I
what order us in category order us
so in I'm not in any particular order
it's a keV Tim and to hear you guys are
my favorite so everyone else I was here
it's if he [ __ ] hates you David so
and I'm not ranking your [ __ ] will
wreck it are you ready yeah for me it's
to hear it number one thank you oh I
love Timmy I'm a Timmy fan always have
been I just you know me and to hear we
got to get a whole energy yeah and Steve
gave my show - I got a new show called
wording his heart on my youtube and he's
like one of the first people that came
out like outside of my immediate circle
yeah who did the show so super thankful
I rank to hear Tim and then Steve green
David so David so and David's oh wow
strong disagreement you should you
should plug your own podcast everyone Oh
put my own podcast well you guys can
subscribe know how is big let's are my
bigness [ __ ] amazing right we just
came out with their new formats yeah and
we get to just talk about our butts and
boobs all day
well we don't even talk about that that
much don't we talk more about our
areolas like do we get specific with it
oh good you really described in detail
right you know like in real good detail
yeah yeah out of the four of us guess
who has the pinkest nipples I know I
don't look for you for it yeah
nut seed not Steve I mean maybe oh poor
women in this room like the pink is I'm
talking like pink nipple well he was
like Bo's can I ask did you guys go to
Home Depot and get a paint gradient
scale it was like brown brown grumpy we
should like a custom color called both
nipples oh wow that's a good man that
may be called pink bows your tongue like
the weight bows his nipples do I don't
mind this type of conversation because
they are great nipples the breasts
they're fine the nipples I wouldn't love
a bouquet of pink bows huh pink bows he
goes roses I just want to happen
are you are you more a breast man a
nipple man I'm an ass man okay yeah but
when it comes to brick when it comes to
breasts man - but wouldn't come to
breasts breasts I do I do enjoy an
important outer or they interact the
nipple part do you do you mind exactly
suck on the outer part do you mind if
the areola is not like in ratio to the
nipple excuse me
so like let's say that the nipple is
this big right so an appropriate areola
would be maybe like like the
circumference of this
Wow that's correct if this was a nipple
in a real it was kind of bigger
would you mind that what do you [ __ ]
with salami you [ __ ] with big new mommy
you know like I do I like the NatGeo
nipples yeah yeah yeah yeah is this a
landing pad for my tongue so it doesn't
matter at all cuz I'm turning off the
lights anyway okay I'm gonna ask you
guys this what is what is the thing that
oh like it's on a woman's body that you
are just always like either pleasantly
surprised or turned off on like there's
a thing like it could be leg hair it
could be nipple size it could be by
Regina lips sauce oh really really too
small or too big
you never know what it's like everyone
is different so it's like okay it's more
accurate thumbprint than I think our
current system yeah okay she did that
you know you know on your phone how you
could like do your thumb I think you
should do it through nipple oh oh oh oh
my god so I found out something crazy
the other day I sent it to my crazy
friend did you guys know that if you go
on your iPhone and you go into the
security and you go into the facial
recognition you can program your own
face into your boyfriend's phone
that's scary things to hear I send it to
my crazy friend and I can confirm that
it works how did you find it but then he
can't get in his photo was your crazy
friend like hey good to know what was
your crazy friend like I know you can
plan an alternate appearance so it you
could do like you without makeup and you
with makeup or something like that so I
was just on a shoot day where I had to
get on my phone very quickly so I turned
off facial recognition and when I went
back to turn it on it said add alternate
appearance and so I this [ __ ] and I was
like program your face it I'm just going
to help all the guys out get it an
iPhone 8 like if any girls are watching
this right now their boyfriend just said
turn that [ __ ] off there was this
tick-tock that I saw where there was
this girl who used to work at the Apple
Store and she was teaching you
step-by-step how no like how to get into
all of your phone's locations every
tower that's ever pinged and the
I'm the location like you can easily
stop you suck oh you could like look oh
where did you say you were you know
what's crazy about all of that
just [ __ ] dump him if you got to do
all this better [ __ ] be looking for
everything let me tell you something you
don't you don't find whatever the [ __ ]
you looking for if you look that hard
okay even if it hangs up the bag you
gonna find something and in your mind
he's gonna tell you like let's let's
pull the string pull it straight if you
are that insecure about your
relationship you have that many doubts
and questions just [ __ ] get out of me
nobody making use things like if you go
back in their history and you find out
that they were horny for someone else
before like that hurts my feelings
no I get that but I mean it's like it's
like would it have been a problem my
friend that is like my crazy friend that
I mentioned she like she calls me one
day and she's just like yeah so I
checked John's phone today and I'm like
calling backup you did what yeah it's
just like a task list item like
absolutely yes she told me that one time
she had found that he had bought nudes
from a girl on snapchat and he had
accessed them like two years later I
don't it's like kiri screencap did or
some [ __ ] like that
and she flipped out on him and he had to
pull out his receipts from PayPal to
show that he bought the nudes two years
ago and I'm just like she's like hey I'm
following my boyfriend right now anyways
what's crazy is like french toast crunch
cereal toast crunch what is that I never
had that following them yeah he's going
the airport I don't know but I had
French I feel like go like whether they
find something or not going through each
other's phones it's just grounds to
break up for you their party yeah like a
hundred why would you need to if there's
trust right and if there's not just why
isn't it just as a conversation y'all
need to have if you don't have full
transparency in your relationship and
it's like ongoing like two years or more
then that's that's a problem within
itself and I know it's hard to talk
about
uncuttable like conversations however
that's something that needs to be done
like you have to have clear
communication otherwise you're just not
gonna make it let's be honest - real
quick for a second okay so me and making
me watch reality television
quite a bit frequently okay we just got
introduced our feet wet and now
Peter so we got sucked dead okay but
sometimes either I'm on my phone or
she's on her phone during the reality TV
session yeah I look over and I'm like
what the [ __ ] is more interesting than
what's going on in Peter Webber's life
tick tock you know I'm saying yeah and
so that's the only time I ever scoop on
this bitch's phone is when I'm like oh
what's better then [ __ ] what's going
on with those crazy [ __ ] hungry for
Peter Webber mmm is that is that the
best thing yeah he's about he was he was
about man yeah I guess it's just like
morbid curiosity to there's me
personally like I trust him I trust my
significant other but also like come on
no I just want to go through my day like
I want to get worried about a little
nugget you know yeah my ex-boyfriend was
the only person I ever looked through
his phone because he was constantly
shady as [ __ ] and it should have been
just ended a relationship but I kept I'd
like to all this other stuff about him
but I just hated the shady [ __ ] and I
would always find [ __ ] and it got to the
point where like even if I saw someone
that had his same phone model I'd want
to break into their phone just want to
look at soldiers need to see shady [ __ ]
enough oh my eyes were trained that boat
has shady [ __ ] yeah never ever felt
compelled to break into his phone you
know once you get into that state of
mind you like at least for me that it's
just like oh did I just turn it yeah
yeah I didn't like who beat me yeah it's
a downward spiral it's never an upward
spiral Oh question for you guys so I met
this girl it was like about a year or so
ago and she casually mentioned that she
and her boyfriend both have locations
turned on and one time he lost reception
in his location was gone and she like
had a full-on meltdown and breakdown and
stuff how do you guys feel about couples
that always have their locations turn
how did she know when he lost reception
unless she's [ __ ] staring that's
scary a really light term but I was like
in case someone kidnaps me people can
find me yes I'll do that I don't even
know how to use that function on my
phone I didn't even know that was an
option I don't think it is but I think
you'd have nothing to wear
I think it's disgusting I think that
time apart is healthy for couples and
relationships like when I go on the road
and I'm going for four or five days I
come home I miss my family so much I
don't want to do anything but be with
them right outside of me being a loner
that really helps with that because like
when I'm not on tour every month or so I
go check into a hotel just to have that
yeah you need that separation so me
turning on my location for you unless
you're out of the country I don't need
to know where you are you don't need to
know I'm N you know what I met for the
most part I'm always filming I'm on a
stage or I'm doing something similar to
that I just need to know where your
heart says that part right now you know
what that service is for your heart yeah
it's always with you babies always if I
get kidnapped on you kidnap Gina I think
that someone would have would shave you
from head to toe I know personally I
would shave your head and I would cut
your arm off and tell you that no one
will ever find you pretty but me baby
and let me tell you something else Gina
if you support off the record you should
because we are brought to you today by
manscape
that's right man's kid who is the best
in men's below-the-belt grooming Oh none
of the men's none of none other then man
so if you already kidnapping you wanted
to shave me what would you use I would
use a man escape 707 thousand rpm may
escape razor do you it does have an LED
light yeah they you can light you can
light your grooming area
it wouldn't work better though to shave
a pair of balls I think rather than Gina
so I would probably yeah I would
probably be the bed is too large to be a
pair of balls this is true the batteries
last for 90 minutes it would take 90
minutes of shave this big-ass [ __ ]
head hmm yeah you lose the flashlight
with the lawnmower 3.0 you yeah it's
called the lawnmower 3.0 my manscape
they got you down so they are saying
right now you can I don't know where the
[ __ ] my brain what like farther they
came out with a lawnmower 3.0 okay this
is the latest in manscaping technology
mhm
they have released it okay we're talking
about using an LED light so you can
light your balls you could be in a hotel
room that
loses power you could be underground
somewhere okay
those coronavirus everywhere and guess
what you still have light because your
LED light Medscape still works okay you
could use it as a survivor coronavirus
will not stop your man's caper damn
straight
did you know that the manscaped
engineering team spent 18 months
perfecting this ball trimmer so you know
you're getting some quality stuff and
they're also saying that you know those
those accidents that you get the little
Nick's on your ball which is real
something of the past this baby so like
people saying we've upgraded to a 7000
RPM motor with it's too much power it's
too much power ecology I disagree with
the amount of power it's not a thing
it's too much power
yeah I agree with you yeah stand on in
this fight for you
you put the shaved balls on your right
it's not like those other not like those
other razors where it's not what's up
and it's like man you're scared use this
scared to put in your balls that you're
just right that's right you know Saint
Patrick's Day is right around the corner
so there's no better time for you to
invest and the proper tools to get lucky
so we're 24 for 20% off and free
shipping
use the code off the record at my
manscaped comm that's 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape comm use the code
off the record no matter what size your
dick is it always looks better when you
trim it all the way down and I think we
have all agree on that
so go to mance keep calm and get that
trimmer and let's get the let's get your
balls back today good a dream never lose
a ball again use Minsky know you guys
have you guys want to do it again do it
good hey listen you know what they had
they had quiet stroke technology so when
you turn that [ __ ] on even though it
sounds like a get power a [ __ ] 747
mmm it stays quiet it actually does
actually
white stroke sounds like what you do
when I'm home in like you don't talk is
like why folks say when you actually do
it in a room full of people and they
don't even know she does that on planes
I'm 46 strokes here right now you guys
nothing to know it oh my god
I'm sorry the ads over can ask is this
campaign just for the balls yes love
that I am the ball girl are you trying
to I tried to use the dudes
buzzer thing on my hoo-ha once and I
[ __ ] pinched and I never would again no
one do that again oh well it's because
you weren't using the you know the lawn
mower the same pays a copy of the man
scoffs oh it was on my Fupa
mmm yeah back back in the days before
like the lawn more like literally get
like squeeze your sack to life get it
smooth so you can go over it with the
like the delivers but now like this one
it doesn't it doesn't paint so I'll be
like I'm reckless all over my ball
sometimes I drink while I do it cuz like
no their new slogan no make some
additions on your dick you know Nick's
honeydukes okay I think it's good yeah
during the break you were mentioning how
this coronavirus stuff is really
affecting your a tour yeah
I am [ __ ] pissed dude I'm mad at the
World Health Organization that they
didn't get on top of this early yeah
it's [ __ ] up like first of all we
don't like it basically is a string of
the flu coronavirus is nothing new if
you go look and last all cans you'll see
coronavirus on the back of Lysol cans
this is nothing new
alright then it's also the fact that
like they get the vaccinations every
year for the flu from Australia I don't
know why but they do they do there's
what they pull it again yeah I don't
know I don't maybe I was like what a
first I don't know having or something
but like that's what it and then there
are different strains of flu but the
main thing is like this is gonna [ __ ] up
a lot of money they were already saying
the like the president was asking any
events that are happening that a 500 or
more to go ahead and counsel but now
comedy club
coming out and saying that that
counseling tours are being cancelled
left and right concept to be see be
disclosed yeah yeah you should have
it's [ __ ] up like we don't have we
don't have anybody we can fall back on
we don't have there's no Union yes no
Union for there's no unemployment for us
there's no health insurance for us and
the president's talking about that we're
gonna wave all these fees but like if
you don't have insurance Perry it
doesn't matter what [ __ ] fees you
gonna wave I'm still gonna end up on
like $2,000 if do you think that they'll
come up with some sort of technology
where you could you stand up and to a
camera and everyone that bought it to
get can have it like other computers
absolutely it's called streaming you can
do that but I'm just trying to figure
how you still collect on the ticket you
are there's literally no way you would
have to have that everybody would have
to have like a home theater system and
like you just hear the laughs yeah
you've been laughs quite laughs like
yeah but I mean even though you said to
go to your house that's a whole really
good service here like FiOS and shave
it's gonna be laggy and some people are
laughing like way too late it's just
awkward is it sucks man like this I got
this tool I was gonna be really good out
for this tour like off a merch in like
the booking of me and like now it's just
like fun but you know more people watch
our friggin hands out there that's
really what it is like is it like even
still like I was traveling this weekend
I still saw people go into the bathroom
I'm not watching a hand dude I see it
every [ __ ] time ago I call it I've
literally been calling it out like I'm
like yo so you not gonna wash your hands
got a boost oh good for you yeah
and then if I get on the plane and I see
you and I know you didn't wash your
hands up like that's crazy this guy in
watch his head what's a bad though you
look at me and I'm like what you're not
gonna fight on the plane and I know I
can take you like the weed away my side
up like I hate hard as [ __ ] Matthew you
if you have a long fight game you could
take like six punches then you might get
me cuz on 7th 8th I'm gonna slow down
but on the first one the six are mama
lights away and that's the difference in
you meet because if I'm about to get in
the fight I'm calling for one one well
you don't want to clog up the lines with
things like that he's not non-emergency
a non-emergency because I wanna call the
9-1-1 lines but I'm also I having it I'm
having a dispute that's very considerate
for one one okay well I mean I know I
can't be I'm not saying that so don't
come to me with the energy levels so
this [ __ ] you sit on JK news first of
all be weird the view at that type of
person watching JK go bug Conor McGregor
Jesus go bug somebody who's fronting
super hard like you're on [ __ ] Jane
is mad but I was just weird to me that
people are still not take it because
there's also weird to me they're like
everybody is like freaking out over this
but aids has been around for like 70
years and people still [ __ ] wrong the
first night that's that's also bizarre
smart way so people still sticking the
head in on the first night you don't
know the faces middle name mm-hmm I knew
Nikki's middle and last you know your
middle okay yeah the first night when he
did the day oh wow I knew his history as
I keep in the same body same girls in
four years I mean I didn't get tested
after I mean usually have to let you go
together the protocol is before yeah I
made an exception for mr. Steve gray
because he was my template for the
perfect man yes
in the heat of the moment is that okay
to like not no no no absolutely not
technically he's a moment no no no I get
it but like like is that before the kids
got crazy by the way I had condoms in
the house you just like
because I was in my dating my whole face
and so it's not hope listen let's let's
dijo a this what women are dating
ultimate man they're just dating
whatever shaming that I'm just watching
try to cut it out slut-shaming I'm
trying I'm trying
oh no it's just day because if a god
does is not holding it's gonna be such a
[ __ ] hot girl summer singers get
dating is when they pay for a dinner
hoeing is where you [ __ ] him in the
bathroom and they didn't even do [ __ ]
what did he get you a drink
that's still the date no heat on my
friend he'll everybody in a shower okay
your drink huh anyway used a condom in
my home phase but I stopped I did I
didn't use it with steam yeah these are
not my favorite stories
[Laughter]
[Music]